The deep blues of water, anamorphic
lenses, and a contemplative MCUstory.
Wakanda Forever passionately
honors the legacy of Chadwick Boseman.
It's no secret that Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever is one of the most
highly-anticipated MCU films so far.
The movie serves both as a sequel to
the beloved 2018 blockbuster Black Panther and
as the climactic finale to Marvel's Phase 4.
And​​ yet, overshadowing all of the excitement
for Wakanda Forever is the notable absence of
actor Chadwick Boseman, who tragically passed
away in 2020 following an extended battle with
colon cancer. From what we've seen thus
far in the trailers for Wakanda Forever,
it's clear that Boseman's legacy will
be a major component of the film itself.
Indeed, it appears that much of the film's
story will be informed by the devastating
loss of Chadwick Boseman. Director Ryan
Coogler confirmed earlier this year when
he said that the cast and crew put their
"love for Chadwick" into the film while
presenting a preview for the movie at San Diego
Comic-Con. In fact, Boseman's impact on Wakanda
Forever is so great that even the film's
visual style was influenced by his passing.
In a recent interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Coogler mentioned how the visual style of the
movie is supposed to reflect the immense
loss felt after Boseman's death. He said:
"I think this film has the fog of loss over
it. Anamorphic lenses warp the image a little
bit. Sometimes when you go through profound
loss, it can warp how you look at the world...
what we were after was just making it feel
tactile, even though it felt like a dream."
Coogler went on to explain that this is meant to
craft a film that is both intimate and emotionally
poignant while operating on the scale of a
massive superhero blockbuster. In addition to
the use of warped lenses, Coogler addressed how
the shift in visual style includes an emphasis
on water and the color blue — something that
should come as no surprise since the film's
primary antagonist, Namor the Sub-Mariner,
is the ruler of a vast undersea kingdom.
"Wakanda will fall."
Of course, since loss and grief have so
heavily informed the storytelling and
style of Wakanda Forever, it's no surprise that
the experience of making it was melancholic for
those who knew and worked with Boseman on the
previous movie. While speaking to Collider,
Winston Duke, who plays M'Baku, explained that
shooting the sequel was strange without their
old colleague on the set. However,
the experience helped them come to
terms with his death and understand
the grieving process. Duke said:
"It was something that we dealt with, every
day, and something that we got to understand,
every day, that we're not the only people
grieving. Not only the people who are in
front of camera are grieving, it's everybody."
Elsewhere, Lupita Nyong'o, who portrays
Nakia, recalled having to meditate, pray,
and reflect in order to come to grips with
the new movie existing without her friend
and co-star. It took the actress a while to
adjust to the idea of a sequel without Boseman,
but she understood that changes were
necessary. She told The New York Times:
"I found myself having to radically
accept that this was going to be
different and that showing up with as
much openness as possible was key."
Wakanda Forever was certainly an emotional
experience for everyone involved — but the
movie promises to honor the legacy
of both Boseman and King T'Challa.